are your co-workers diabolical if they
mock your lack of follicles
perhaps you should not let your words be
careless around a co-worker who's
hairless
a judge in the uk they have them there
cat has ruled that a man calling a man
bald counts as sexual harassment
according to the ruling baldness is more
common in men
than in women
if they say so but i'm no biologist
so using bald as an insult against the
guy violates the protected
characteristic of sex similar to
commenting on the size of a woman's
breasts
but anyone who thinks that boobs are
more common in women than in men clearly
have never seen brian stelter jogging
terrible
actually that's no one has seen brian
selter jogging so
the joke doesn't even work
cat this is the assumption that only men
are bald but we know that's not true
this is actually reverse sexism
yeah so if it's
sexual harassment to comment on a man
being bald because men are bald more
often
women may wear hair extensions more
often than men so is making jokes about
someone's hair extension sexual
harassment
look baldi
i'm just curious
are you wearing what your dog was
chewing on no those were old ones but i
still can't throw them i'm a hoarder
like
really like after that they really
should go in the trash and i thought
that after that i'd be able to throw
them in the trash but they're still
sitting on the counter oh my god
he really enjoyed it i guess he probably
was getting you know he felt like he was
killing a dead animal
and in some ways he was
well yeah yeah larry uh what if a bald
man identifies as a bald woman then
all bets are off
that's very hard because of the pronoun
issue yes exactly very hard this is the
second story we've had on sexual
harassment and pronouns i don't know
i mean
what happens greg yes just thinking this
through
sexually harassed what about short
people
dude that's on my list
i had a question about short people i
mean i don't i don't know how to deal
with this you know no you know i'm very
sensitive to this issue
who uh does some high privilege on me
jesse waters all the time has to make a
comment about height i never do that to
dana well i know
i know
i'm i'm taking a pass here i'm in way
over my head
well you know dana do you uh do you
think that this is uh
calling
referencing somebody's baldness is a
sexual harassment i do not um it's but
it's like because this is the second
story we've done about sexual harassment
and it's nonsense yeah it's like the way
when when the love started calling
everyone racist it just became a word
with no meaning yes and so now sexual
harassment which is a problem for some
people in some companies is it yeah it
is not an issue in middle school and
bald men are not i can't imagine that
this judge in the uk was like oh this is
a very interesting case i'm so glad i
get to rule on it i would have just
thrown everybody out of the courtroom
is there a lot of money in the
settlement
i was curious about that too
enough to get like maybe a hair
transplant you know
jamie this won't be a problem for about
a year for you
but
um
you know what's funny what did you i
read every word of the article like i do
with all the articles
at the end of this the he's angry
because the guy called him bald but if
you read it further i'm trying to say
this as clean as possible his co-worker
called him a bald
c word
that's what he called him and the guy
was like oh my god i can't believe you
called me bald yes
this is not the crazy that would be like
someone if someone's like you're a fat
pedophile and you're like i've been
going to the gym
i have that
in england okay
i was gonna tell you one short true
story so after i do your show sometimes
you go on twitter or something and
people say like nice things or whatever
and i was after after a show i was the
last one in the new studio i was looking
i was trying to feel better about myself
and people were like oh you did a good
job like oh that's nice heart
and
and then somebody goes i love the new
camp where the camera like pans across
it it gives us a great view of jamie's
bold spot
there it is
yeah and so i actually ended up i ended
up going to this doctor and i go how
much would it be to get like a little
like and it's it's thousands of dollars
yes and he goes i could make you look 20
years younger with this and you just
gave me a ball cap
[Music]
i'm gonna that totally covers it there
you go literally it does cover it i feel
very self-conscious no don't i'm sorry
larry
i'm sorry larry you're offended huh are
you offended well depending on the
settlement though yes
[Laughter]
all right
up next if kamala is at the venue word
salad is on the menu
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else